foreign
[Music]
with the forging of the great pronouns
three were given to the Twigs slender
androgynous and queerest of all beings
[Music]
to the power bottoms
great reverse Miners and plunderers of
the chocolate horse
and nine nine pronouns were gifted to
women with septum piercings who Above
All Else
desire power
for Within These pronouns was bound to
the strengthened will to govern each
space
but they were all of them deceived
for another pronoun was made
in the lad of Twitter in the fires of
Mount bio
the dark lord they them forced in secret
and master pronoun and into this pronoun
they'd imported cruelty they thems
married and they them thrilled who
dominate all life
one pronoun to rule them all
what does it say Frodo I I don't
understand it
I don't understand Gandalf it's because
it's stupid
hello humans I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's June 12 2023 we're
live streaming on Rumble locals and
YouTube subscribe if you haven't and
join us for a post game show immediately
after today's program and yes as the
cold opened may have uh LED you to know
even more than you would know inherently
uh it is still pride month pronouns
genitals being chopped off all of the
stuff that comes with pride is still
happening uh although it is being pushed
back against more and more and more oh
by the way I want to give a shout out to
Florida man Chuck from our Rubin
report.locals.com Community who
submitted that cold open those are the
types of benefits that members of our
locals Community get you might just get
your video or video you like to the team
and then we can play it on the show
that's what's going on over there we'll
also be announcing uh we're gonna do a
little promo this week some giveaways we
were going through the official Ruben
report closet we've got a closet back
there filled with merchandise and all
kinds of things we're clearing it out
for the uh the upcoming fall season
we're going to do a bunch of giveaways
for annual subscribers so hang tight
we'll have more on that in a day or two
uh but yes the theme of the show today
is the endless
tranzing of America and how most people
have absolutely had it but for some
reason a certain set of people are still
afraid to say anything about it so while
the White House and the elderly man who
sniffs the hair of young children uh
while he is pushing the transiting of
children on us people like Joe Rogan and
other taste makers Elon Musk etc etc are
finally pushing back and uh and really
more than anything else what does it
take what do we always talk about what
does it take to stop this stuff how
about a little can conviction how about
standing up with your shoulders back
telling the world what you actually
believe resetting this thing and then we
get back to some normalcy
I think we can do it before we get to
that let's talk about my Patriot Supply
and then the big program on the other
side guys are you concerned about having
enough food to eat in case of a sudden
emergency grocery stores can get
stripped bare within hours if you don't
have backup food on hand you might find
yourself relying on the government
don't let that happen my Patriot Supply
is making a special offer to help
everyone prepare for what's coming act
now and you'll get a three-month
emergency food kit plus free free water
filtration system so you can have clean
water to drink and cook with you're my
Patriot Supply three month food kit
gives you a wide variety of delicious
meals and it provides over 2 000
calories a day which is highly important
for keeping up your strength and energy
order today and get your free gravity
powered water filtration system a 279
dollar value as a bonus gift the food
and your free water filter are all
shipped to your doorstep in discreet
boxes with free shipping included as
well go to prepare with reuben.com
prepare with reuben.com and now back to
me all right
so Joe Rogan I've mentioned him once or
twice on this show he's a popular
podcaster couple hundred million people
listen to him every month he's just had
it with pride uh here he is discussing
his feelings on target Bud Light
Shopping kids genitals off and all that
good stuff
Target lost billions of dollars because
they tried to have this Pride selection
oh yeah gay mannequins yeah they well
they had all these like Pride children's
shirts and gay children yeah and then
obviously the Bud Light thing with Dylan
Mulvaney they've lost 20 plus billion
dollars you imagine you're just gonna
send a can to some confused
person that uh day 365 a Womanhood and
you send that person a can with
their face on and your company loses 20
billion dollars
that is wild man so we're seeing that
now well we never saw that before where
people are going enough right enough
stop shoving this down everybody's
throat when I go to Target I don't want
to see like
yeah tuck pants where you like they're
designed to help you tuck your dick like
hey that's not normal and I don't want
that right in front of everybody right
that really is the issue does it have to
be out there in front of everybody and
again does it have to be aimed towards
kids these things that are sold for
adults that is one thing but you know
when you walk into Target although I
checked a couple weeks ago at my target
uh here in Florida they did not have
that giant display so I think in certain
places they're marketing towards Their
audience which by the way that is what a
business is supposed to do if you're in
a more conservative area you might not
want to put the tar the tucking Target
close right up front up front but if you
want to do that in your San Francisco or
New York City store you can of course
you put the stuff up front that's most
likely what's going to be stolen first
and you know in certain cities like Los
Angeles you're allowed to steal up to I
think it's 970 worth of stuff that's an
awful lot of tucking clothes for you and
the family but really the point point of
all that was that a guy like Rogan who I
think just kind of the magic of Joe
Rogan is he just kind of represents the
average dude right like just like a sane
normal dude he's not pretending to be
anything other than what he is and he's
had it and then the people that watch
him listen to him that by Bud Light that
maybe shop at Target they've all had it
and that's the beauty because this is an
organic movement you know we're used
we're used to in the last five seven
years being in this cancel culture
situation where there's this very
inorganic feeling of people being
canceled someone says one off-color
thing taken slightly out of context and
the Machine fires them they're kicked
off their TV show they're fired at work
whatever it might be and it doesn't feel
authentic or organic there's something
about people just being like I'm
actually just not going to shop there
anymore that feels very authentic and
that shows that you have some uh you
have some skin in the game you have some
autonomy to put into this and go oh my
choices actually mean something now what
I want to jump from that which was just
a couple days ago that video we showed
you all the way back to
2017. that's right we're going back six
seven years because you may remember
that me and Jordan Peterson and Sam
Harris Ben Shapiro Rogan Etc we were
part of this thing that was coined the
intellectual dark web the IDW and it was
basically it was a Barry Weiss article
that was the front page of the New York
Times and it was basically that there's
this group of people online who are
talking about things that are important
to talk about but nobody's talking about
them on mainstream and then we got a
whole bunch of hate for it and thing
kind of it blew up in terms of views and
content and all that also kind of then
caused tensions between us anyway the
point is we were discussing a lot of
this stuff before everybody was
discussing it now it's you know a lot of
people are just waking up to this stuff
in 2023 and like oh my God they suddenly
want to trans all the kids but again
there were plenty of us discussing it
and warning about it way back when what
do I always say what put Jordan Peterson
on the map it was Bill c-16 in Canada
which was that the government was going
to punish you if you used someone's uh
if you didn't use someone's preferred
pronouns so now I want to jump back to
2017 here is Ben Shapiro on Joe Rogan
warning about all of this stuff
what scares the out of me is when
you hear these stories about people
deciding that their child who's like
eight or nine years old beyond belief
it's scary because you can't a nine year
like a 17 year old doesn't know that was
the thing about the Ruby Rose girl she
was saying that when she was young when
she was a teenager she wanted to be a
man she wanted to be transgender and
that she had gone through that phase now
she's so happy that she didn't do
anything right well did they say that
that 80 percent of kids who experience
any sort of gender dysphoria as children
grow out of it so when you have a
society that reinforces it and then in
Canada they're now having they're
passing laws now that say that if a kid
says you know you have a girl and the
girl says I'm a boy and she's three that
the government can come into your house
and take the kid because obviously if
you if you don't want a humor the kid
and get the kid treatment or surgery or
or hormone blockers then you're
obviously doing something wrong to the
kid this is just it's insane first of
all if anyone tried to do that with my
kid I would meet them at the door with a
gun I mean that this is this is the kind
of stuff where you're talking legit
Civil War like when when you say that
the government can take people's kids
from from them because the government
knows better than you how to parent your
kids on basic things like are you a boy
or a girl you know that clip right there
what Ben said at the end like uh if you
tried to take my kids away you would
meet uh me at the door with a gun that
went very viral people tried to cancel a
Ben that he was threatening law
enforcement and everything else but this
idea that the state could take your kids
away I have Phoenix doing a little
digging right now but just over the last
couple days California has basically
said that if you as a parent do not
affirm what your child is saying about
their gender that the state actually
could get involved that's literally
happening in California right at this
very moment okay I got some info on that
under California's
ab957 a parent could lose custody for
not quote affirming whatever their child
believes about their gender here the
bill author defends this bill using
example of a seven-year-old who
announces their gender doesn't match
their sex so we'll we'll play the video
that that's referencing we'll play that
on tomorrow's show but it is literally
happening right now and remember as I
always say we should not be calling this
gender affirming surgery the least
affirming thing you could do to a child
is chop their genitals off right that is
not affirming their gender it's actually
pretty unaffirming of their gender uh
also Ben makes an interesting point that
I think is is worth repeating that 80
percent of these kids outgrow this that
also seems to be why this radical
movement is going after the kids and
going after them younger and younger and
younger first off all of you everyone
watching this has met a five-year-old at
some point and most of you probably were
five-year-olds five-year-olds do not
think about these things seven-year-olds
do not think about sex and gender and
any of these things so once you can get
in their minds and start confusing them
think about the Litany of other things
that you can then get them to be
confused about and that seems to be what
our corporations and what our government
wants so the average person the average
guy who buys Bud Light shops at Target
or used to buy Bud Light and used to
shop at Target perhaps still watches The
Joe Rogan show they have just about had
it but the machine just keeps coming top
down here is Joe Biden the elderly man
with dementia who sniffs little girl's
hair the guy who's pretending to be
president but clearly is not pulling the
strings uh here he is at a Pride
Celebration in this past weekend
it's wrong that extreme officials are
pushing hateful bills targeting
transgender children terrifying families
and criminalizing doctors
these are our kids these are our
neighbors it's cruel there's callous not
somebody else's kids they're all our
kids no you old windbag they're the
parents kids that's all my kids are not
your kids okay I don't understand how
anyone could think anything other also
the idea that somehow the government
should come in and force this which is
what they're trying to do in California
and that Joe Biden I mean mind muddled
stammering
buffoon Joe Biden thinks that it is the
government's purview to have anything to
do with any of this okay so what states
are doing you know it it's happening it
started here in Florida but now it's
happening in a whole bunch of other
states they are saying if you perform
these surgeries on kids if you
chemically castrate children think about
what that is if you give kids drugs that
stop their natural hormonal processes
you will lose your license and you will
possibly end up in jail now if you do it
as an adult meaning they are now 18 or
whatever the legal age is in that state
then so be it right and this is what a
mature society would do but it's not
just that Joe Biden is just saying it
he's celebrating it and he's really
pushing to legally Advance it at every
level and scare the hell out of
everybody who pushes against it we'll
get to that on the other side let me
talk to you about gen yacel real quick
guys here's the biggest summer secret to
a great looking glowing summer
complexion it's a lot more than staying
hydrated and using sun protection it's
having great skin care products from our
friends at geniusell Sun humidity
dehydrated skin covered in dark spots
and even puffier bags under the eyes are
all a problem for all of us but
thankfully geniusell has the perfect
answer introducing genucel's beautifully
curated summer Essentials package that's
right this limited edition package
includes their one-of-a-kind Ultra
retinol super moisturizer that uses a
powerful plant to extract alternative to
retinol without the harsh side effects
and perfectly is perfectly safe to use
in that summer sun plus you'll get
geniusella's classic skin care therapy
for under eye bags and puffiness and
concentrated vitamin C serum to nourish
your skin for a visibly clear complexion
with a glow that'll get you compliments
everywhere you go go to genucel.com
Reuben right now to get your geniusell
summer Essentials package right now and
just for the summer every subscription
order includes a customized summer spa
gift box absolutely free order now in
every summer package includes
geniusella's immediate effects also free
with its immediate effects results are
guaranteed in 12 hours or less or you
get your money back don't wait go to
genucel.com Reuben that's randycell.com
Reuben and now back to me so yes this
gender stuff this chopping of kids
genitals off this sexualizing of
children and everything else it's not
coming from the bottom up it's coming
from the top down it is coming from our
federal government it's coming from our
institutions literally our military
institutions at this point it's coming
from our corporate institutions and
that's what we really have to think
about it's not
just the average person that is trying
to push this on everybody right when we
showed you those videos last week of
Glendale California right it's a suburb
of Los Angeles and all these parents are
out there pushing against their kids
being sexualized in school and if you
watch the way the mainstream media
covered it it was it was usually framed
something like this it was like anti-lgb
protesters versus Pro LGBT protesters
and it's like
what do you mean anti-lgbt these are
just parents these are just parents who
don't want state workers talking to
their kids about sex they're not
anti-lgbt protesters you're actually
kind of turning them into that but
that's not really what they are they
were fine a year ago when you weren't
talking to their kids about sex but the
point is this is all top down why is it
that these corporations and the
government want everybody to be trans
and put up trans Flags instead of
American flags and everything else well
here is Joe Biden making up some
complete nonsense again during more
Pride celebrations this weekend
we have to act as a nation
we need to push back against the
hundreds of callus and cynical bills and
laws introduced in States targeting
transgender children
terrifying families and criminalizing
doctors and nurses these bills and laws
attack the most basic values and
freedoms we have As Americans that's not
hyperbole it's a fact
no it's hyperbole it's not a fact you
buffoon we did a bunch of searching for
these hundreds of evil bills and here's
what we came up with
crickets people crickets there are no
anti-lgbtq bills there are no bills to
stop gay people from doing everything
straight people can do there are no
bills to stop lesbians from playing
rugby or bisexuals from turning their
hair purple or trans people from doing
anything they want to do again this is
about
chemically castrating children and for
some reason that elderly man with
dementia is really into it and if you
think about it like this Joe Biden
obviously has dementia or something else
if an 80 year old man came let's say
you're walking down the street with your
kids just on a beautiful day you're just
taking a walk you got the dog you got
the kids and then an old man walks up to
you and he's kind of stiff and you oh
that's an old man that looks like a nice
old man and imagine that old man walked
up and he whispered because he's always
whispering
chemically castrate your children can I
sniff their hair first you might say
okay this is the type of guy we don't
want to be around but for some reason
this man apparently is the president of
the United States anyway here's some of
his plans to help families chop their
children's genitals off
this year we're committing more Mental
Health Resources and new funding for
programs to help families support and
affirm their kids
a new federal initiative to address the
lgbq homelessness
the lgbq homeless first up he just got
rid of the tea there right I like how he
just forgot about the teas all together
but lgbq homelessness you know what the
problem is because these gays have very
high taste so you try to take a poor gay
person a homeless gapers and you put
them into just some average hotel room
and they're like I can't look at those
blinds I can't live in this place it's
all so stupid but if you really listen
to what he's saying he's saying we're
going to put more money for the mental
health what that means is they are the
government is going to take money from
some people to put it into programs that
will encourage that other people have
their kids genitals chopped off we've
said a genital chop-off uh statement
record here today do you see why this is
nuts when they create these programs do
you think the government would ever
create a program where let's say there
was okay
completely kidding aside for just a
second let's say there was a kid let's
say there was a 13 year old boy who was
actually really confused about their
gender identity so they're a 13 year old
boy who's effeminate most likely they
are just gay perhaps they're actually
straight and it's just a phase but
whatever most likely they're just gay
which is why I always say that there's
nothing more anti-gay than the trans
movement right because they literally
want to you got it with these with these
poor gay kids okay but let's say this
kid this boy is confused about his
gender identity now the government has
put money towards mental health and
programs do you think there is any
chance in High Health that the kid now
goes to this facility or the the
guidance counselor at school or whatever
the mechanism is that this program would
be instituted do you think there is any
chance in hell that they would do
anything other than encourage this kid
to become trans do you think they were
there would be any chance in hell that
the government would hire a therapist
who would hack actually do the work of
sitting there with the child and really
trying to figure out what the root of
the issue is and actually you know this
is your body and even if we do these
hundreds of thousands of dollars
of extremely painful surgeries and even
if the bill is foot by somebody else and
everything else you may not be happier
you actually may end up with a penis
that does not work or a vagina that is
not fully functional or anything else
like check some of the pictures on and
videos on this stuff if you have not
seen it it is it is extraordinarily evil
but so that you really just have to
understand when Biden and all these
people applaud it right they applaud
like seals we will put more money to a
firm children's gender so you really
have a bunch of brainwashed NPCs saying
we will put money other people's money
to chop kids oh God it's evil uh here's
Biden just completely making something
up all together which I guess shouldn't
surprise anybody
when a person can be married in the
morning and thrown out of the restaurant
for being gay in the afternoon something
is still very wrong in America
where Joe where is this happening
where are lesbians getting married then
going to Waffle House and being kicked
out it is not happening I don't know why
something about lesbians at Waffle House
seem funny to me where are gay guys
getting married in the morning first off
most people don't get married in the
morning people get married in the
evening it's a general rule okay but
even so two gay guys they get married
and where do they want to have lunch
about uh Dave and Busters okay I don't
know where do they want to go no
Wingstop whatever they want to have a
slice of pizza you think the pizza guy's
like you gay guys get out of here with
your new marriage we're not serving you
pepperoni it's all absolutely ridiculous
they are unearthing things that we have
long put to bed we also have laws there
is the Civil Rights Act you cannot
discriminate uh on sexual identity or
skin color or these things we already
have these laws so this is just complete
and utter nonsense and by the way
generally speaking even if we didn't
have these laws and you know there's a
lot of libertarian arguments uh that we
shouldn't even have the Civil Rights Act
because in essence if you own a building
uh you own a building you own a uh a
store or whatever a service whatever it
might be you should be allowed to you
know exchange whoever you want if you
want to be a prejudiced dick like you
should be able to that would be like the
purely libertarian argument on that the
reason that there's some validity to
that partly is because most people that
started business aren't like I'm going
to discriminate against the black people
I'm not going to serve salads to gays
like it's just not a thing right it's
just not a thing anyway and wokeness
which I've referenced this Twitter
account a couple times uh on uh on the
show they had this uh which I thought
was pretty interesting because as you're
seeing there are those flags that's this
past weekend at the Capitol the death of
a Nation summed up in two photos that's
Andrew Jackson
the statue of Andrew Jackson which of
course was vandalized in everything else
during our Summer of Love a couple years
ago and now we have the pride flag with
the American flag you know as I
mentioned uh was it last week when we
showed you that video of the guy outside
the prime minister's office in Canada
where they took down the Canadian flag
and they put up that gay flag what you
must understand is that is a political
message that gay flag does not represent
a sexual like simply represent a
sexuality whatever the hell that would
even mean it represents a political idea
that is based in collectivism and
communism and Equity right that's what
it is and as we decide that we will take
down our flag our like no no stop doing
this nonsense here's another one from
and wokeness
so this is a from a pride parade I guess
over the weekend and it's like again
there is somebody who appears to be
naked or pretty damn close to it
twerking in front of a small child
guys whatever you do in the privacy of
your own home it's fine
do whatever you want to work in front of
the mirror in front of whoever it is
that you'll live with stop doing it in
public with children but they cannot
stop themselves and and this is so
consistent with something we've seen
from the left for these last 10 years
right at any point when the left did
something that was a little bit nuts
antifa BLM all of the stuff every time a
voice on the left
remember a guy like me eight years ago
every time a voice on the left said hey
can we can we ease up on like the total
craziness of everything they Purge you
so there's no one to stop them there's I
have no doubt that at the average Pride
Parade uh that there are plenty of
decent good people but this thing has
been hijacked and they don't know how to
stop it because they don't have enough
people that have the wherewithal and the
convictions to stop it uh but the
interesting thing again is that this is
about the kids it's about the kids so
let's continue on this because it starts
with you got a some guy or girl or
whatever with whatever genitals twerking
in front of that little kid and now you
all know Leah Thomas Leah Thomas is a
guy who was ranked something like
467th as a male High School swimmer then
Leah Thomas said that he was a chick and
he became the number one female swimmer
Riley Gaines who we've talked about a
bunch uh who who was second in the last
race that Leah Thomas won Ron DeSantis
decided to go ahead and award her uh the
the gold medal the first place medal
anyway and Riley Gaines is now an
outspoken Advocate against having dudes
in chick Sports old school I know anyway
uh Leah Thomas was interviewed what what
was this for was this the vice or like
one it's one of these things you can see
it's a they them interviewer and they're
talking to Leah Thomas about trans and
dudes swimming with chicks and the whole
damn thing take a look
the NCAA has said that they support
trans athletes they also haven't taken
action against states that have banned
trans athletes Leah can two truths exist
at once I think it's very difficult for
for an organization to say we support
trans people we support trans inclusion
and then not do anything to sort of
do that to anything to protect trans
athletes to ensure uh they're they're
treated fairly it's sort of
gets to this this broader idea that I've
encountered a lot where people will say
oh like Leah I respect you and your
identity as a woman but I just don't
think it's fair for you to play in the
women's category and you can't have that
sort of
halfway acceptance of of trans women and
of trans people more broadly because
when you think like that you're not
really
thinking of trans women as women you're
thinking of um as
this other category that we have to find
something to do with when we're just
other women who want to compete
no you are not other women who want to
compete you are a dude you have a penis
this is where I mentioned the Connor
propeller penis Theory which is that
Leah Thomas has kept the penis to swim
as a woman using the penis as some kind
of propeller for extra propulsion okay
so no I don't ex I don't respect you as
a woman I don't respect your pronouns or
anything else you're a dude who is a
marginal swimmer at best who is now
smacking down actual women and you're
doing it in the name of diversity and
tolerance you're you're a fraud and a
phony that's what you are but speaking
of Fraud and phone he's a little more
from Joe Biden this one actually isn't
about genitals Hallelujah this was just
about masks in covid you are not going
to believe this one from clay Travis the
Biden White House is requiring College
athletes who won national championships
and haven't gotten the kovid shot to
wear masks and maintain six feet of
social distancing on their White House
visit Monday uh when he's saying this is
indefensible first off I just love that
picture of Joe Biden like it's just like
the perfect that sums up whatever the
Joe Biden presidency is but do you
realize what an absolute farce this is
it's all everything's of ours we are in
Non-Stop Forest Town okay that's where
we're at with everything today that is
happening today they're bringing all
these college athletes in and if you did
not get the shot the shot that did not
work the shot that has all sorts of side
effects the shot that there was no
reason for you to get as a young college
athlete you're most likely in pretty
good shape and you probably take care of
yourself and you're young and strong and
have an immune system and everything
else if you did not do all that still
now at the White House which is run
apparently by a man with dementia we are
going to force you to put a mask on
which subsequently even bouchi admits
does not work and six feet social
distancing which was a theory that was
based in nothing it was literally based
in nothing Dave would you calm down it's
Monday fine all right I will
um what's the moral here guys the moral
is that Biden and this Administration
and this machine is infringing on
everyone's privacy everyone's sanity and
all of our rights with their mandates
and now literally their alterations of
our bodies so what do you need to Bear
the storm what do you need and are there
examples of people doing it you need
conviction okay and yes there are
examples of people doing it I want to
throw you to something from February of
2022 this is a little over a year ago
this is Novak Djokovic who basically is
the best male he is a male tennis player
of all time and you may remember that he
did not want to get uh the covid vaccine
he has an incredible not only physical
regimen uh but but nutrition regimen I
mean he's famous for this like a team of
people that are studying his body
science and everything else he was not
even allowed to compete in the Australia
Open last Feb February because he was
not vaccinated anyway here he is in
February 22 talking about freedom of
choice and bodily autonomy
uh those were things that the lefties
used to talk about remember my body my
choice but uh here he is a year and a
half ago and you'll see why I'm showing
this to you in just a moment
I understand the consequences of my
decision and one of the consequences of
my decision was not going to Australia
and I was prepared not to go and I
understand that not being vaccinated
today I you know I'm unable to travel to
most of the tournaments at the moment
and that's the price you're willing to
pay that that is the price that I'm
willing to pay ultimately
are you prepared to forgo
the chance to be the greatest player
that ever picked up a racket
statistically
because you feel so strongly about this
Jab
yes
it's a really evil question the way that
it was framed because he is the best
male tennis player of all time I think
now he has 23 Grand Slam wins if I'm not
mistaken and you know the idea that
somehow that was that wouldn't be true
the guy with the guy meant was okay if
you don't if you don't compete in more
of these because you didn't get back you
won't be the greatest of all time but
the point is he has conviction right I
don't need this thing and I am willing
to do what is right and it will cost me
money it will cost me treasure it will
cost me accolades Fame
etc etc now you may remember that even
three months ago three months ago this
headline from The Daily News uh Daily
Mail Novak Djokovic is denied entry to
the U.S again and will miss the Miami
open okay now you also might remember
that at one point uh Governor DeSantis
was trying to figure out a way to get
Djokovic in they were going to like
Charter a boat that would somehow get
him to the Bahamas then into Florida and
anyway that didn't happen long story
short you know what did happen over the
weekend so the guy did not get the
vaccine he missed a couple opens he
probably could have several other Grand
Slam wins uh in his belt right now well
he did win the French Open this past
weekend uh his 23rd Grand Slam title
here's a little video
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a hero right there that's
actually a modern hero not only uh is he
the greatest male tennis player in
history but he stood up for what was
right he did the right thing and he will
be he'll be rewarded at the most sort of
personal and and spiritual level uh but
he also showed people that you don't
have to just take it you don't have to
relentlessly be the of the system
and they want us all to be the
right Leah Thomas wants all those girls
to be the Joe Biden wants all of
you to be the oh whatever crazy
thing we come up with today and by the
way it's going to be way crazier in a
couple years you better freaking do it
or we will kick you out of the country
we will punish you financially we'll
close your bank account if you're in
Canada
etc etc so you guys get it standing up
for what you think is right is the only
way out of all of this and when you
stand up for what is right you actually
become less neurotic you become less
sort of endlessly self-introspective to
the point of nasal gaze Naval gazing and
then what happens is you start actually
living the life you're supposed to now
so I want to do a little bit of a
transition there because Djokovic did
not take the drug they wanted him to
take and they seem to want to drug
everybody right they want to chemically
castrate kids they want to force you to
be injected with their mRNA technology
by the way it was nice to see a Djokovic
as he fell to the ground it was so
refreshing to see an athlete who wasn't
falling to the ground because of a heart
attack he was just falling to the ground
out of sheer joy and exhaustion so that
was nice but in any event they are
trying to basically drug everybody
constantly right we know this we know
this and that brought us to this video
we've been trying to figure out a way to
get this into the show for a little
while now you may remember this this is
from how long is this ago this is about
10 years ago right this is about a
decade ago listen to Tom Cruise yeah Tom
Cruise that Tom Cruise talking about the
coercive use of
ADHD drugs Sr SSRI drugs and how they
are pushing that stuff on children this
is 10 years ago take a look
here we are today where I talk out
against drugs
and psychiatric abuses of electric
shocking people okay against their will
of drugging children with them not
knowing the effects of these drugs do
you know what Adderall is do you know
Ritalin do you know now that Ritalin is
a street drug
do you understand that the difference is
a question Matt I'm asking a question I
understand there's abuse of all of these
things now you see here's the problem
you don't know the history of Psychiatry
I do all it does is mask the problem
Matt and if you understand the history
of it it masks the problem
that's what it does
that's all it does
you're not getting to the reason why
there is no such thing as a chemical
imbalance I'm saying that drugs aren't
the answer that these these drugs are
very dangerous they're mind-altering
antipsychotic drugs and there are ways
of doing it without that so that we
don't end up in A Brave New World
okay I'm not testifying to every single
thing that Tom Cruise said there like is
there no such thing as a chemical
imbalance like I'm not sure about that
but I thought it was interesting because
uh that clip almost got him canceled 10
years ago
um because uh there's a giant machine a
giant big Pharma machine that wants you
injected with things oh your kid's kind
of Jumpy we better put him on drugs oh
your kid's climbing around a lot you
better put them on drugs I can tell you
having these two kids downstairs what I
have learned if I've learned anything in
the last nine months of having these two
boys Justin is a higher wire act this
kid he is an Explorer he wants to climb
and crawl into every crazy position if I
leave the back door open for a split
second he wants to bolt out of the house
he climbs on everything he's knocking
himself over trying to get upstairs like
it is built into this kid to go out
there and conquer the world and I'm
gonna do everything that I can to give
him all the tools so that he can go
about his life and do that Justin's more
he just kind of Luke is more he just
kind of sits there and stares at you
he's more of a thinker but they're wired
a certain way but we have decided that
we will draw oh you're a boy but you
think you're a girl will drug you we'll
chemically castrate you oh you're
actually uh this kid's a little too
energetic we'll drug him this kid
doesn't have enough energy we'll drug
him we we are
grewing around with the chemicals in our
brain and then we wonder why we now have
a generation of people that don't know
what their what gender they are and on
top of the fact and this is a big No-No
to talk about it comes out almost every
single time that these School shooters
are on these drugs right so when Joy
read remember the the Uvalde shooting
where they they I mean that was one of
the worst where they shot I think it was
18 elementary school kids and three
teachers and Joy Reid dared to get on
her show that night and say that the
shooter did not have mental health
problems it was about the gun right
which by the very definition if you
shoot children innocent children you
have a mental health problem of course
it also turned out that they were on
these drugs over and over they are but
some people have been warning about this
right so I started today's show talking
about Rogan and Ben Shapiro and I
mentioned that intellectual dark web
thing and there was Jordan Peterson
Brett Weinstein and a whole bunch of
other people talking about the hard
issues of the day and I guess we talked
about them for a while it didn't stop
anything but we woke up a certain amount
of people but Jordan I think has been
sort of the the Pinnacle of the Pinnacle
of all of this and there actually is a
solution you don't just have to drug
your children there is actually another
way to go about doing it
we use amphetamines to conveniently
modify the behavior of bored boys
because we're too stupid to construct
our education systems in a manner that
doesn't drive the Mad
yeah hyperactivity is an iatrogenic
disease created by schools yeah that's
that's the case so
boys should play more way more than they
do way more they should play to the
point of exhaustion in some sense every
day really really they'll quit when
they've had enough
I bet your hyperactive son has no
trouble paying attention when he's
playing video games
[Music]
it's worth thinking about isn't it oh
the video game one really is worth
thinking about right you can sit the kid
down who can't sit still right all day
long but he can sit still in front of a
video game there's something there but
again do you see this thing we have an
entire generation for the last probably
decade and a half maybe even two decades
that we have drugged on all of these
things and now we see the shootings we
see the gender confusion we also know
that this thing actually ended up making
us less social not more social and we
wonder why everyone's walking around in
Perpetual craziness and we wonder why we
elect officials who want to do horrible
things to kids
and and all the rest of it
all the rest of it you know I'll tell
you something on uh you know the
weekends I I just on a personal note 10
in the show sometimes I find the
weekend's actually a little more
difficult for me personally than the
weekdays because the weekdays I'm I'm
busy right like so I'm doing the show I
do other hits I'm writing I'm taking
calls I'm taking meetings whatever might
be going on with the shows and with
locals and everything else I'm very very
busy from say like seven to usually
about six o'clock but you know every
time I go downstairs for lunch I'm
always trying to play with the kids for
a little bit and in the morning I take
them solo and do my thing on the
weekends because I'm not working in that
sense although I'm always working a
little bit uh you know it's just it's
just us and the kids and it's like it's
just craziness all the time and these
kids as I said Justin especially like
just wants to be everywhere and he's
pulling actually I had to go to Home
Depot this weekend because he's pulling
wallpaper off the walls and I had to get
wallpaper glue and like it's just
craziness so in those brief moments that
you need as a parent that you need like
a little bit of Sanity I could see why
parents give them the iPad or put you
know put them in front of the video game
or TVs or anything else there is this
chick on YouTube uh Miss Rachel
she first up this woman Miss Rachel
she's completely ruined my YouTube
viewing history because I used to have
all my basketball games on there I had
like Star Wars stuff and whatever now
I'm all Miss Rachel this Miss Rachel if
I just need like 10 minutes of just
quiet for a second like Justin's going
crazy and I'm like I just need a second
man I gotta pee like something like that
I put on Miss Rachel and then he can
just sit there and he smiles and she's
she's quite good actually this is one of
the few that is quite good so I'm not
saying that there is no use for devices
no use for TVs or anything else but the
point is David always says me you know
we don't want to do that too much right
you don't want to do that much because
you want them to do what Jordan said you
want them to play to the point of
exhaustion but we've built school
systems that put them in this chair all
day long they end up going nuts and then
you drug them and then they don't know
which gender they are
did we tie this whole thing together I
think we did guys we have a machine
that wants to vax you when you don't
need to be vaccinated it wants to
mutilate you when you don't want to be
mutilated and I've had frankly just
about enough of it so how about we let
them how about you get some balls and
then they will not chop their balls off
I guess that was the message for today's
show it's Monday guys which means it's
me Monday over at
reubenreport.locals.com here's the one
that I put up
the United States and the world stand
with Ukraine it just depends what you
mean by stand we've got a couple hundred
other people in there putting up their
fun memes of the day uh we got a post
game show coming up for you in just
about a minute and my full interview
from uh Hungary from Budapest Hungary uh
with the capital of the background it's
a really beautiful location that we did
it with balash Orban who is prime
minister Victor orban's political
director no relation same last name no
relation that is up right now also last
week we put up the full interview in
Jerusalem with former Ambassador David
Friedman that's up right now the
documentary that we shot there we're
still in the middle of putting together
tying some little pieces together on
that so we'll have more on that a little
bit cold closed Disney style and we'll
see everybody on the post game in just a
moment
oh
so what do you think
black
[Music]